i think it's been remarkable um
to have this level of panic uh you know
governor newsom
for example closed the zoos again now if
you're going to lock up
every poor child in los angeles or san
diego or san francisco
so that they're they're in a little
apartment uh they have no space
and then you're gonna close all the
public parks
uh what are these little kids supposed
to do and and it strikes me
that what you end up with is a public
health dictatorship
which is very singular in how it
measures things
i had a university president say to me
the other day
that he will lose more young people to
suicide
and drunk driving then he will lose to
covet
and he said they're reopening
he cannot understand why people have any
doubt at all about reopening
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report reminder everybody to subscribe
to our youtube channel and click that
pesky notification bell
and joining me today is the former
speaker of the house the author of over
40 books and the chairman of gingrich
360 consulting
newt gingrich welcome to the reuben
report well it's good to be with you
exciting i'm glad to have you you are in
rome
at the moment what's what's going on in
rome these days
well as you know my wife calista is the
ambassador to the vatican
so that's why we're here rome actually
has had a huge comeback they
got in big trouble back in february
because
there are about a hundred thousand
chinese workers in northern italy
and they were allowing the flights
to continue so they were literally
flying in from wuhan
bringing the disease right here and it
got so out of control
that their hospital system was breaking
down and they were starting to triage
people and if you were over 80
they basically said you're not getting
we're not going to take care of you
he in fact kalista helped samaritan's
purse
uh franklin graham's operation they flew
in an entire hospital
uh 68 beds 60 doctors and nurses into
the worst hit part of northern italy
so the italian government closed
everything down we had
grocery stores pharmacies
gas stations that's it
if you were in the street
you had to have a good excuse in writing
or you could be fined three thousand two
hundred dollars
so for ten weeks cluster ran the embassy
from our house virtually
we do amazing amount of zoom and go to
meeting and what have you
and for 10 weeks they basically starved
the virus
and gradually got it under control it's
now sufficiently under control
that they've reopened the restaurants
the museums
uh public parks stores
and you see people walking around now
problem for italy is about 14 of their
economy one out of every seven dollars
is tourism and they don't have any
tourism yet
so places like the coliseum last year
got 23
000 people a day you know they maybe
have 500 or a thousand a day
and so but that's a real economic crisis
for them but
but but in terms of the uh pandemic
they are in dramatically dramatically
better shape today
yeah so we're holding this interview for
a couple days so i don't want to ask you
anything about specifically what's
happening today but
but generally speaking the way you see
the lockdown now in america and i'm here
in los angeles and
and literally just yesterday newsom put
us put us in another lockdown and
that these things seem to keep
continually happening we're watching
some spikes you know it just seems
that no one knows who to trust at the
moment uh
what's your take about how the states
have done it where
where trump fits into this and is there
something that you
would have been doing differently as
speaker of the house to to push your
guys
to push certain things uh differently
well i think i think it's been
remarkable
um to have this level of panic
uh you know governor newsom for example
closed the zoos again now
if you're going to lock up every poor
child in los angeles
or san diego or san francisco so that
they're
they're in a little apartment uh they
have no space
and then you're going to close all the
public parks
uh what are these little kids supposed
to do and and it strikes me
that what you end up with is a public
health dictatorship which is
very singular in how it measures things
uh i had a
university president say to me the other
day that he will lose
more young people to suicide and drunk
driving
than he will lose to covet and
[Music]
he said they're reopening he cannot
understand
why people have any doubt at all about
reopening and so i would start from
there
the people you need to worry about half
of all the deaths
are people who are over 70 years of age
and in particular
the more you go up at 80 years it's more
dangerous at 90 it's even more dangerous
so you know that you want to really work
to protect
people who are over 70 but you don't
need to really work to protect people
who are 13.
and the idea that we're we've gone from
a country that used to know how to open
one house
school rooms and have seven classes in
one room
and people actually learned how to read
to an extraordinarily expensive
union-dominated bureaucracy that doesn't
want to teach
and you can have this in los angeles
they've got it in new york i mean
they have in fairfax county virginia one
of the biggest and richest
school districts in the country why
would we pay people to not teach
why would we have all these big fancy
buildings nobody can go to
and i think it really raises very
profound questions
about the whole system yeah well that
actually is perfect segue because i was
going to say as someone that's a true
lover
of american history and has written
about it and you talk about american
history all the time
are you sort of shocked the way the
average american person just sort of
takes orders and doesn't necessarily
ask why are these things happening you
know at one time it was flat in the
curve
we don't hear the phrase flatten the
curve anymore we haven't heard it
excuse me for about six weeks now it
seems to be something else or they just
give us an order
and they don't really tell you why well
i mean
part of it has been i think the
evolution from a
news media to a propaganda media so that
you have these
waves of coverage i compared it to
watching the flagellante in the middle
ages this was a group
that would go from city to city beating
themselves and so you have all these
people out here
who or they panic um
you know the the truth is if you look at
the death rate there's no reason to
panic
uh this is not the bubonic plague
it's it's not ebola uh most people who
get
first of all an amazing percentage who
get the
um the by the chinese virus which is
what it is
most of them don't even know they have
it um
you told somebody tested positive who
was quote asymptomatic
that means whatever symptoms they had
were so mild
that it didn't affect them so you have
to then stop and say wait a second
why are we panicking over people
you know the numbers go up but the
numbers go up with people under 35
who are totally healthy uh and i think
the i have been truly appalled my
younger daughter jack
bushman as a certified financial analyst
and used to run a very large budget
billion dollar plus budget and she said
to me the other night and just
sheer disgust she said i have never seen
statistics
put together so badly that it is
impossible to know what's actually
happening
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our
full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell